- McDonald-duh.
- McDonald.
- Duh.
(upbeat music)
Hi, I'm Evan,
and I'm here in my
mother land South Korea,
Seoul,
with a few of my American friends,
and we are about to try
some Korean McDonald's.
A.k.a. McDonald-duh.
The items on the menu here,
I heard it's really crazy.
It's a lot different
than the ones in America,
let's see if you like it.
- So we are having Korean McDonald's.
Me for the first time,
you for the first time in what?
- Fifteen years, I think.
I'm not a huge fast food guy so,
even though I visit Korea,
I actually never visit McDonald's.
This is as new to me as it is to you.
- I haven't had that much McDonald's.
I probably had it when I
was a kid a couple of times.
I'm willing to try it
because we're in Korea.
- I think I'm going to
enjoy Korean McDonald's
because I'm all about those options.
I've been dying to try it.
- Let's do this.
- Double,
Bulgogi,
burger.
- [Andrew] Wow, this is saucy.
- Kinda looks like sausage.
- You know when you picture Bulgogi,
it's like sliced, shredded meat.
I was expecting to see like
Arby's roast beef burger.
- It does smell like Bulgogi though.
- It's a double sausage patty burger
with some Bulgogi marinade on it.
- It's pretty good.
- Yeah. I don't hate it.
- Not bad, but not Bulgogi.
- It is really saucy though.
A little bit too saucy for me, saucy boy.
(speak foreign language)
(men laughing loudly)
- The Supreme Shrimp burger.
Koreans are really into
their shrimp-y snacks.
Then their squid-y snacks.
- I got to tell you something, Steven.
- What?
- I'm allergic to shrimp.
- [Steven] Fine, give it to me.
- It is so shrimp-y inside.
- Wait, there's actual shrimp in there.
- It's actually a shrimp.
I was expecting a paste.
- This is the fish-o-filet of Korea.
- It's got that popcorn shrimp taste,
that battered, fried shrimp appeal.
Shrimp-y.
- McSpicy Shanghai chicken burger.
- Got a big ol' chicken thing happening.
- This is probably the
only fast food burger
that the patty is actually
bigger than the bun.
(loud chewing)
- Okay.
- It's a little bit spicy,
but all of the spice is coming
from inside the chicken.
- You can taste the chicken
a lot better than you can
taste the chicken in America.
- The chicken is not mushy at all.
The texture of the meat is there.
- It's general chewy spiciness.
- It's not like pepper spicy.
You're not getting the different flavor
you would get from a jalapeno
or something like that.
- I got that spice coming in
on the back when I chewed in.
It's like flirting with my mouth.
- Churro.
Does that say churro?
(speaks foreign language)
- There's a serious amount of
the cinnamon sugar on here.
- You know, it's definitely not a churro,
but I would buy it just because it's good.
- There's three different sauce options.
- Strawberry, which is
apparently radioactive.
- [Adam] It's like alien blood.
- Very sweet.
- If you just melted down
some strawberry lollipops,
that's what this dip is like.
- Caramel. Oh that's thick.
- It's probably the way
to go with this one.
- I would just eat it plain, to be honest.
- Yeah. It's already sweet.
- So bread-y. It's so dense.
I do enjoy it.
- How do you say chocolate in Korean?
(speaks foreign language)
- It's distinctly Hershey's syrup.
- Exactly what I was gonna say.
- Okay. Overall, I do enjoy McDonald's.
McDonald's in Asia is more
upscale, more luxurious.
I enjoyed the foods that were here.
- The spicy chicken burger,
I think that was really great.
If these burgers were
presented in America...
- [Steven] Oh yeah.
- I feel crazy right now.
(upbeat music)
(squeaking)